buddy today and be speaking to you about
the response of Staphylococcus aureus
Klebsiella pneumoniae and streptococcus
pneumoniae on plant-derived
nutraceuticals now it is very
interesting to note that with our
natural sources we can find that our
plant materials welcoming quite handy in
helping us to on earth different
scientific properties of rare plants now
this particular research looked at this
particular research looks at ginger the
official name is in the beer of the
Sonali a leo and Barbra Lisa's mellow
Allium CEPA three varieties of Allium
Allium sativum and these varieties of
plant eater suta calls were used as
though there were antibiotics on
Staphylococcus aureus Klebsiella
pneumoniae and streptococcus pneumoniae
and these were the microorganisms that
were employed in this research based on
the frequency with which these organisms
are implicated in many illnesses that
are reported now the findings um were
somewhat what we expected but not to the
magnitude to which we found now the
finding them findings demonstrated at
garlic in all its concentrations with
both methods disk diffusion and
turbidity and in all its combinations
produced remarkable zones of inhibition
against all microorganisms that were
tested ginger showed no zones
of inhibition regardless of the
combination except though when it was
combined with an with garlic the the
onions the different varieties of onions
also showed some amount of inhibition
however the inhibition that was observed
was was an intermediate while galangal
and there was no zone of inhibition seen
therefore or conclusion basic conclusion
was that the antimicrobial properties
were not been able to extract the
methodologies that we were able to use
now what was um quite outstanding for us
when we compared the zones that were
produced by garlic with the conventional
antimicrobial treatments we found that
the zone of inhibition for the garlic it
was far greater than that of some of the
leading antibiotics that are noted to be
used for treatment for these these
microbes now the while we used a
combination of different types of
nutraceuticals and these were already
named the variety of the the onions
which is the Allium CEPA and the the
garlic we found that the different
varieties of the garlic of the onion um
I should say did not have any vast
difference the differences that we found
was more so with the garlic the garlic
in itself is very much potent the
microorganisms were confirmed and
identified by a microbiologist while an
agronomist assisted in the
identification of the nutraceuticals
that were used and this brings us to the
end of this quick summary quite a basic
what eye opening and so I know that this
will bring us to doing some additional
studies with these nutriceuticals
because there
quite a bit of antimicrobial or perhaps
even antifungal properties that we can
find and we can extract these to use in
the treatment of our patients and of
course when we will see sutra sutra
calls there they produce a little or no
significant harm to the patient's so
here we go